hello hi
all of you lovely people watching from
the future thank you so much for
stopping by
i am playing five nights at freddy's
pizzeria simulator which is actually
i really like this one i don't know if a
lot of people like this one as much as
the other ones but i thoroughly enjoyed
it because of the different aspects of
it you still get the same five nights at
freddy's feel
but also you get this weird simulator of
building your own restaurant hello
hi
hi thank you so much for being here
hello hi
how are you
it's been a while
hello
i'm alive
yes hi
my name is markiplier and i'm here
to revisit five nights at freddy's
pizzeria simulator which is a game
uh that came out after sister location
an odd one to follow up on that one just
because sister location is so well loved
and i even i playing it again really
really loved it
you thought i was busy i am busy because
also the reason why i'm here is to tell
you if you haven't watched in space with
markiplier it's out now there's a link
in the description below that will take
you to the project that i have spent
over a year working on and i think that
you will thoroughly enjoy it
i guess yeah i know i know
um but i am incredibly proud of it and
also i just wanted to say seriously
sincerely thank you guys everyone who
has enjoyed the series and has
really like
torn it apart like rabid animals ripping
it to and fro
gnashing it in your teeth
thank you
seriously i know i was uh hyping it up a
lot and i was saying a lot about it and
um
there's still work to be done
because part two
is still being worked on
and i know that's probably a spoiler if
you haven't seen the show yet you should
probably go see it because
in just a little bit of time you're
gonna see even more of it when i told
you that it was big
i wasn't lying
i wasn't lying at all
but i
pulled the fast one on you yeah
so if you haven't seen it already there
is a link in the description below but i
am here to try out pizzeria simulator
and the first thing that we need to do
in pizzeria simulator
is to design
our pizza now i believe last time i went
pepperoni and black olives because that
is my pizza of choice but i'm going to
let you decide
what other ingredients
if i could spell properly
ingredients uh
we're gonna just
you get one more i'll give you one more
it's sausage onions
mushroom or peppers
what is actually nah i'll
i'll do it this way
so i'm putting a poll in the chat right
now if you want to decide what the pizza
is going to be you can list it
in the poll right there what other one
are we gonna put on our pizza
we're doing this democratically because
that's the only way that we can do this
logically anyway
oh who puts mushrooms i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna question it it's fine
video quality ain't good then you
probably need to re-up it to a higher
quality um i seem to be good on my
streaming side of things so i'm pretty
sure that
okay that's a good choice it seems to be
almost unanimously sausage at least over
50 for sausage
so
we'll go with that all right pepperoni
sausage and alls that's actually not a
bad
that's not a bad pizza mushrooms is
second place but it's a distant second
place so i think we're gonna go
pepperoni sausage and olives which is a
pretty good pizza
that's not a bad pizza i'm gonna go with
that one
all right
so before we get into this pizzeria
simulator is different and i think i've
said that for the past few
five nights at freddy's revisits here
there was no option for pineapple and
also you're wrong and please leave
gull
but uh
i've said that it's different in a lot
of these games but this one actually is
quite different the only one more
different than this one is probably
ultimate custom night now i don't think
i'm gonna be able to do revisits at
least live stream revisits of the
virtual reality version of this game um
but
such is the way that things are what am
i doing here
well i don't remember this at all
i
i legitimately don't remember this
i don't remember this
at all
when was this a part of it
what
oh my god
who are you is that lefty lefty is the
one that i put on the thumbnail i can't
remember if there was like some super
deep lore
to lefty
but i feel like there was
right if i throw it at him okay i
legitimately not even lying
i don't remember
any of this
i guess i don't remember a lot about
pizzeria simulator
i think what i need to do
well once i get past this nonsense
right the puppet god all right spoilers
everybody leave me to actually discover
what this is all about how many pizzas
can i stack up
okay you
shut up
[ __ ]
there we go
oh my god
oh my god
that's not so good
oh boy
okay
how do i not remember this
how do i not remember any of this
okay
ah right this is what i remember i think
i don't remember any of that because
this was so jarring to go from that
to suddenly go to this
high
because like this isn't just baby this
is like some freaky
nightmare version
of baby which five nights at freddy's
four had the nightmare versions of the
animatronics
but this one is especially nightmarish
why is it so dark
my light one okay hold on
hold on spooky scary stuff happening
very spooky very scary hold on oh god
what have i done
hold on hold on
there we go
i have light
it was uh it was in my twitch i'm
yelling at you mode which is not what
this is it's not what this is at all
um
all right let's get back to the game
here
all right so this is where things start
to go a little strange scrap baby that's
what the name of it was
yeah it's
this is what i remember the most out of
this because one thing that these games
definitely did
well
was make you feel uncomfortable
and i think that
the entire experience of five nights at
freddie and feeling uncomfortable really
gets distilled down to this moment where
you are sitting across from a table
from one of these animatronics that has
spent the past five games murdering you
and so this is not a pleasant state to
be
it's exactly where i am it's extremely
uncomfy
so
right oh the
the evaluation
begin tape
leaving dead space
three
two
one
the purpose of this tape is to test
automated response times and reactions
from vintage interactive attractions
following audio stimuli if you are
playing this tape that means that not
only have you been checking outside at
the end of every shift as you were
instructed to do
but also that you have found something
that meets the criteria of your special
obligations under paragraph four
follow these instructions document
response times then safely secure the
space before leaving upon sealing the
room you are not to return
begin audio prompt in three
two
one
[Music]
document results
begin audio prompt in three
two
one
this is so spooky
it's just so spooky document results
it's so weird
begin audio prompt in three
two
one
[Music]
document results
begin audio prompt in three you know
oh yeah
hi
hello
it's a new day it's your time to shine
it's time to take your career into your
own hands you've saved money your whole
life great now it's time to put all your
eggs into one basket and take a huge
gamble on your future run a gamble that
comes with a 100 chance of success in
some cases boy what are we talking about
we're talking about becoming a fazbear
entertainment franchisee that's right
restaurant ownership and management
something almost anyone can do with a
limited degree of success
sure it's a lot of money to invest but
everyone's doing it and that means it's
safe and lucrative
with your initial investment you'll
receive everything you need to get
started including a small room some
tables and electricity
but don't forget about the money you
have left over after buying your
franchise package
use it to decorate by a stage buy
attractions and animatronics and much
much more
now let's take a look at a few things
that will help you get started as a
fazbear entertainment franchisee such as
atmosphere
making sure your establishment has an
inviting atmosphere is essential to
bringing in new customers
entertainment having a lot of
entertainment value in your restaurant
will ensure that customers come back
bonus revenue
coin operated games and attractions can
generate additional revenue during the
day which means more money in your
pocket ready for reinvestment health and
safety there may be times when you
purchase something of questionable
quality and we don't blame you cutting
corners is just good business
but there are steps you can take to
ensure you don't get sued for it and
that brings us to
liability
being a thrifty shopper is smart but be
aware that buying things on sale comes
with a certain amount of risk
aside from the daily risk of lawsuits
there's also the risk that something
might be hiding inside whatever you just
purchased with that steeply discounted
price tag
of course that would only be a serious
danger if there were something outside
that's been trying to get in for months
now which we are not confirming to be
the case this concludes the amount of
help we're legally obligated to provide
remember you are now the face of the
newly rebranded freddy fazbear's pizza
let's wear that smile with pride and
let's make some money
entertainment is not responsible for
disappearance death or dismemberment
let's make some money
okay
so before i get into this i did want to
talk about one thing which uh i don't
know if all of you guys have seen it
but i actually made a project
that was related to exactly what we just
saw
at the desk and noah this isn't just a
plug for space i legitimately
legitimately mean it
um
i'm gonna pull it up here
i don't know if you guys have all uh
if you all remember this if you all have
seen this or
anything of the like of the such as this
i want to show you
this
well
that's terrifying
one moment
marginally better
ah there we are
welcome
pretend i remembered your name here this
is a pre-recorded message anyway i would
not want to be in the same building as
that thing i tell you me anyway thank
you whoever you are for agreeing to test
out the wharf stash automated interview
automaton or
for short let's start off with some
quick calibration all you need to do is
sit back relax and listen for some
numbers okay here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
now what did you hear numbers good
numbers keep in mind i have no idea what
you're actually going to say due to the
fact that as i said before this message
is pre-recorded but if you did hear
something now would be the time to speak
up
so
don't be shy i'm sure nothing bad will
happen i don't know what you're going to
say so if it does happen it will happen
and if it doesn't happen it won't happen
that's how deterministic reality works
so if you uh if you've seen this before
this is the worst automated interview
automaton or
for short uh i made this because um i
was working with the 3d modeler i
believe emil macko and uh they they've
made like five nights after these fan
games and i have this idea for this um
but this is directly
inspired by almost a rip-off of the
concept
of sitting at a table across from an
animatronic that is going to kill you
and i just
really truly enjoyed
making this like i obviously didn't make
3d models but i enjoyed and loved making
the sound design for it because
obviously it's just like
it's 3d models in sound that's all it is
but it's interactive so before we go
forward on the other one i'm going to do
a poll
and you guys can pick which
option we get because this is
interactive much like my project in
space with markiplier that just released
which link is in the description down
there below you can click on it if you
haven't seen it already but this is
interactive so i'm going to say like
which uh like
did you hear the numbers
i think i heard numbers
and sounded like nightmare garbage to me
sounded like nightmare garbage all right
so i'm putting up the poll now um
yeah so
vote and i will decide which way that we
go here if you haven't tried this for
yourself you got to look on my channel
for it but it is called the wharf sash
automated interview automaton
sounded like neighbor
i mean you're not wrong
you're really truly not wrong here
it did
sound like nightmare garbage
uh-huh okay all right
all right seems to be leaning towards
the nightmare garbage i'll give it a few
more few more moments to go no i i like
it's it's not it's not far for me to say
that a lot of things that i have played
and a lot of the like media that i've
consumed in my ten years now that i've
been doing youtube uh which if you
didn't know my 10-year anniversary was
on monday when space release so i have
now officially been doing youtube for
about 10 years but a lot of like the
things that i've made have been inspired
by the things that i've played and i
think that's a beautiful thing i'm not
saying that this is a beautiful thing
but i think the concept of it
people often like turn their noses up at
like derivative work or you know tracing
if you will but to me it's like
this is a completely different
interpretation of it it's like in the
vein of like animatronics but it's it's
also just like it's so very worth
stashed to do this
anyway sounded like nightmare garbage
i don't know i just like it's very fun
oh i forgot to mention please do not say
the word nightmare or uh garbage or
nightmare garbage or any combination of
those words
the why is just a little bit sensitive
you know a little touchy feely well not
really a touchy feeling well well
actually really touchy feely depending
on your definition of touchy and feely
it's really good
i completely forgot
this like is this so me just laughing at
my own jugs
i like okay have i ever talked about how
i how i maybe
made this house it's like that's that's
the animus rock going i tell you me
which is just something that works just
said
for [ __ ] ever um but there was
actually my my
adobe audition bugged out and it didn't
work
all right so i'm gonna go with i think i
heard numbers that's great or bad not
really sure what you said but i choose
to remain positive and assume that you
are still alive which means that our
automated friend here is operating well
within acceptable murder parameters
we're one step closer to mass production
the ward demands more interviews and i
can't be everywhere at once all the time
only some of the time even you might
land an interview someday
maybe probably not really depends on how
the effective minutes go on to the next
test
asian the fundamental basis of any good
interview getting the goods out of those
stubborn interviewees the wire will say
a word and you just say back to the
things pops into your little head
simple right
probably good luck
initializing
word association training
please respond
response unclear
increasing aggression
round
three
okay
all right
so the next option clearly is uh
let's see please respond
but you didn't say anything
uh
potato salad
please
please
respond
i'm sorry
i didn't get that
please
respond
all right fine you win
a potato
this month's accepted
word association training protocol
nurse dearest next of kin i regret to
inform you the orderly beloved and or
most despised has regrettably but not
unexpectedly become recently deceased in
the line of duty be comforted in the
knowledge that their demise was just as
likely to be quick and painless as it
was so an agonizing please do not
respond to this voicemail this number
has already been disconnected
all right let's do it for me that's
scenario now onto uh the survivors
wow potato salad a real thinker you but
the test has been passed with flying
colors and you're still alive and
speaking of flying others our next test
is about something called
um synthetic linguistics
that's not made up but the point is you
can have a good interview if the wire
isn't able to conjure up the right words
in the right situations so our friend is
going to fire off some random words and
you just try to spoil anything that
doesn't make any sense all right
although pretty much everything is going
to make any sense because
our n words
i believe in you
initializing speech training protocol
yes
no
baby
left
right
[Music]
[Music]
um
blue
yellow
pink
sound
so how'd it go did you hear anything
weird
don't be shy or do or are you are you
alive
are they alive
i didn't kill them
i don't know if they're dead i'm just
asking can a man ask if someone's alive
or dead
anyway yeah uh yeah i'm dead hello
are you live down there give me a sign
through the multiverse now i'm
empowering uh how can i tell if you're
dead
uh i'll flip a coin off let me go ahead
ah
eyes heads i didn't call it in the air
who's hesitant oh
head is dead
anyway okay oh there's more i forgot
time
there's still time for you to see in
space with markiplier link is in the
description below if you haven't checked
it out or this you can find them down
there below
you're gonna love it and i'm gonna love
that you love it and we all love anyway
back to the pizzeria simulator the link
is in the description if you haven't
checked it out yet or if you haven't
seen all the secrets in there yet the
link is in the description below okay
anyway
i just i i for i actually forgot about
that i forgot about that until literally
i saw that table there
and it's one of those things where i've
made so many things in in the 10 years
i've been on youtube that
i
forget what i've done and then i'm like
oh yeah i like that
let's see how much cash you had left
over after purchasing your franchise
package
great that should be more than enough
now let's get started
on your left are your product catalogs
you can unlock more expensive catalogs
by simply purchasing items for your
pizzeria
use the arrows in the bottom right of
the item window to browse the products
for each catalog
when you're finished shopping click the
button labeled blueprint mode to place
your items
you can switch back and forth between
catalog mode and blueprint mode as often
as you like before opening your doors to
the public
when you're ready to open your
restaurant for business for the day
click the button labeled finished in
blueprint mode give it a try and do some
shopping
i
really truly love this whole concept of
buying things um
i'm just gonna try to buy the most
dangerous things for the disco
so anything with a liability risk
oh but that is bonus revenue
i do like bonus revenue
but obviously it's not a five nights at
freddy's thing if you don't have
animatronics right most of the
animatronics
oh hell yeah
number one great
god i just i freaking love it i just
love it so much so i think the first
thing i'm gonna do is i'm actually gonna
buy
animatronics because it's not
five nights at freddy's if you don't
have animatronics
i love mr hugs
and i love that he's a liability
and i love number one create i don't
think if there's anything else with
liability risk
so we gotta have number one created oh
wow
[Music]
wow look at all that actually uh good
stuff that i can't afford
well whatever
time to plop down and get this thing
going
call man
sponsorship offer
hell yeah give me some more stuff can i
upgrade can i go back to the catalog
hell yeah
all right let me place down uh mr hugs
and number one crate there oh yeah oh
yeah
oh yeah all right what do we have here
well these aren't liabilities
these aren't liabilities at all
net bear i don't have enough money
i don't think lefty's available just yet
but lefty will soon be about oh hell
yeah discount ball pit
i can't put any more animatronics down i
could put a duck on
bonus revenue out of that one
uh
bonus revenue out of that one see what i
can plop down there
all right you
there we go that's looking good
balloons add coin slot
oh yeah you can play test these i forgot
i forgot that you could play that
right
[Music]
right
[Music]
whoa
100 smackers
wow
and
i'm ready
[Music]
oh right oh god
okay here we
go oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
the best
[Music]
i just this game is so adorable
and terrifying which i don't understand
how you get a game that is both adorable
and terrifying at the same time but
that's what this game really
has done
which is stunning
it's stunning that this is the way that
it is
who defunked that
uh oh yeah stage well i don't have
enough for that stage i can't even fit
you guys on there but i can't yeah the
candy cadet
this is the one that actually had like
the lore i know i'm not gonna get like
shadow bonnie lucky again
but uh it did have lore
play test i am a candy cadet come get
your candy here i have candy all day
every day candy candy candy
return to candy cadet again and maybe i
will tell you a story
okay
okay
hey
all right
i am a candy cadet come get your candy
here what why have candy all day every
day
i know there was
yes candy
return to candy cadet again and maybe i
will tell you a story
maybe
what are the odds to get something
creepy
i am a candy cadet come get your candy
here i have candy all day every day
candy candy candy
[Music]
return to candy cadet again and maybe i
will tell you a story
i did it i don't know what i did but i
did it
all right i am just i haven't even
opened
come enough your candy here i have candy
all day every day candy candy candy
now i will tell you a story about a
little boy
he had a red a snake that he kept in a
metal cage whose hunger could not be
satisfied one day the boy found five
baby kittens outside his house
he brought them inside and kept them in
a shoebox
he knew that the snake might kill them
but could not bring himself to get rid
of the snake
he knew that if he chose one kitten to
feed to the snake it might be satisfied
but he could not choose
so he went to bed leaving the cage open
the snake went to the shoebox chose a
kitten at random and at it after five
nights had gone by the boy was full of
regret and cut snake open
he pieced the remains together and put
the kitten back into the shoebox
[Music]
wow was that rare
did i get a rare thing
did i did i do it
what are the odds i don't know why am i
getting all the rare stuff in my
revisits
on the first try
[Music]
10 chance okay well that's not that
extreme that's not that but i do
remember i don't think i got a story
when i was actually playing this for
realsies
so you know
you know what else is rare
the extremely rare link in the
description below that'll take you to my
exceptionally rare youtube original show
in space with markiplier part one
why don't you go check it out for
yourself anyway i gotta buy more [ __ ]
link in the description go check it out
it's lovely oh i gotta buy a bigger
place i guess
upgrade
oh damn
i'm already uh
kind of rolling in it
i guess i'll buy more
uh
[Music]
i don't remember what the qualification
to get the next category is but i guess
i can get some animatronics in here
sure
why not
all right
uh
oh right you can only have one stage
well number one crate i apologize
as much as i love you
and everyone loves you
oh swivel hands is good
but i want
a liability from ned bear
let's net it up sorry bud swam
there we go
now we're talking
now we're talking did i get another one
i want that uh
the other thing what was the other thing
i don't remember you know the thing
isn't it
[Music]
hey
look at that
wow that's a liability that's an extreme
liability
[Music]
interesting listen guys it's fine y'all
are worried for nothing i'm a pro
in case you didn't remember
i'm the king
[Music]
why can't i put any more down
oh you're already there oh
[Music]
well all right
well what else could i get
[Music]
i don't think i can get anything else
i'll actually have to you know play the
game
which is [ __ ] i know but
at the same time
novelty
i don't think there's any more
interactables sanitation station
discount cooling unit
bucket bob mr can do
handstand paper pals
[Music]
sure
lights i can't afford lights or anything
else okay i think i'm done
wow look at this place i think this
might be the best first day
i've ever had
i'm done here
all right let's see what's up your
restaurant is now officially open i know
awesome that doesn't mean your job is
finished however you have a lot of work
to do while patrons eat their pizza in
the other room
from your terminal you have supplies to
buy papers to print and repairs to make
once you've taken care of all the items
on your to-do list you can log off for
the day and get out of there
money for supplies and repairs comes out
of petty cash so don't worry about it
coming out of your pocket we've got you
covered the only money you have to worry
about is if you choose to upgrade any of
the equipment in your office
now onto other matters
something to be aware of is that the
ventilation system and your terminal are
pretty loud and may prevent you from
hearing things in adjoining air vents
that won't be a problem if there is
nothing in the vents however if you feel
that something might be in the vents you
have a few tools at your disposal to
protect yourself
you can shut off your terminal and the
ventilation system at any time to
decrease the amount of attention you are
drawing to yourself
also shining your light directly into a
vent will most likely prevent anything
from jumping out
you also have three tools available from
the terminal itself there is a motion
detector an audio decoy and a secondary
ventilation unit
keep in mind
that you can only have one of these
active at any given time
now get to it
simply log off when you've completed
your tasks for the day and you can go
get some coffee
okay cool i don't remember how to play
this at all
i know there's stuff about
about like music and
motion detecting and whatnot and
i don't remember how to play
why would i remember
why would i remember how to play
i don't period
does the motion detector like constantly
work
i do remember that i need to like cycle
on the
the vent because it is
quite
quite expensive
quite expensive
i don't remember what was i saying i
don't remember what i was saying
is there anything happen do it'll tell
me right it would tell me it would tell
me if there was a motion to detect
right
it would just it would tell
look up what do you mean look up what's
up
what do you mean off are you goofing me
i do remember there being something
about up but i don't
i don't think
but why did i need to turn off my
terminal
why would i need to do this
why would i need to do that why would
that be a thing that i need to do
also how am i unclogging the toilets
remotely
there's nothing behind me you silly
but there is something below me a link
to in space with markiplier my latest
show put a lot of work into it would
love for you to check it out thank you
so much
link is in the description to all the
secret lore or five nights at freddy's
just look for the link that says it's me
if you see in the description some words
that say it's me you've unlocked the
secret of the description that's a
special link just for you that no one
else can access
you must be lucky you must be special
only you can solve the mystery that's
down there below
what i got away here of course
whoa
what
why did my flashlight
am i done
did i do it
i did it
right am i done
i'm done right
shouldn't i be able to hear that music
oh god
all right i'm gonna log off i think i'm
good
great job it looks like you're getting
the hang of this
now let's just focus on getting you
through your first week there's a big
party here saturday and you should view
that day as your ultimate test make it
through saturday and you will have
proven yourself as the successful
entrepreneur that we all know you can be
that's me baby
there's me
congratulations on completing your first
day however your job isn't over just yet
there is another aspect to your end of
day routine
and that is inspecting and salvaging any
animatronics found in the alley outside
the back door
things are found here quite often
and while we aren't sure why
what we do know is that they can be used
for parts which can mean a much needed
revenue boost before starting your next
day
of course as with everything else in
this line of work those benefits come
with risk
the safest thing to do is to throw it
back outside but then you get no money
for the salvage
choose to keep it and you run the risk
of certain negative consequences namely
death
should the item in question not be as
docile as it first appeared
if you do decide to try to salvage it
then you must complete the maintenance
checklist during this testing phase
check on the animatronic frequently if
you feel that it is becoming unstable
use the taser provided to you
you can use it three times without
damaging the hardware
every use over three however will
decrease the item's salvage value
before you is an animatronic found in
the back alley we are unsure of its
origins
it is your job to complete the
maintenance checklist before claiming it
as salvage or if you choose to you can
throw it back into the alley where you
found it and forfeit payment please make
your choice now
i will salvage it you have chosen to
proceed with the maintenance checklist
remember use your company as you taser
to return the animatronic to a neutral
state if you feel that it's becoming
unstable or aggressive
you can only use it three times before
it begins to damage the animatronic and
decrease its value
begin audio prompt in three
two
one i like that blood
you're not gonna get me
document results
no results
stop that
yeah get back there get back there
begin audio prompt in three
two one
[Music]
document results
hey
back up there pal okay so there's
multiple stages of forward i think that
i can get away with just the one begin
audio
one
yeah you can't boot this mood
unfortunately i wish you could but you
can
[Laughter]
document results
that's a little too close there pal
that's a little close i'd take the other
one but that one's a little too close
okay in audio prompt in three
two
one
[Laughter]
document results
begin audio prompt in three this is fine
too this is totally fine i'm fine with
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
document results
you have completed the maintenance
checklist and may proceed with the
salvage
well done end tape
you're coming with me buddy thanks for
letting me join the bar hey no problem
no problem pal hey welcome to the team
you're
a-okay in my book
you're a-okay
yeah
no new lawsuits that's a lot of money
holy crap
i'm rich
i'm
rich oh yeah we gotta get the deluxe uh
but i need to make more money
hmm
sponsorship hell yeah
oh marty's plumbers
all right i guess we could do
[Music]
let's see if we can buy something i'm
sure there's something we could buy
something that's going to get us a lot
of money
i mean that's a good amount of money
that's some good money right
[Music]
does
there
does that dude that i salvaged like up
here anywhere here
i forget what it is
i like the ball bit tower
better than the other bit
i mean i'll have both for now they're
going to have dueling ball pits right up
front
what do i do what
oh
what
[Music]
oh oh i gotta wait until it says press
space and then reaction it okay i see i
see okay
[Music]
100 bucks that's it
well that was pitiful and a waste of
money hmm i wonder what other goodies
you can probably get from that probably
a lot honestly mark down
hey
it's affordable
it's a deal
it's a steal even put it right in there
put her there
let's play test that bad boy what do i
do
[Music]
all right
serious model
[Music]
that's what i say
that's what i always say
lawsuit lawsuit you know what i mean
lawsuit
no one cares mark down
yes
another discount give it to me
i love this
we got some real discounts going on here
look at all
marked down
yeah but i don't need that that's health
and safety that's not for me
all right
[Music]
uh that's good entertainment that's
decent entertainment um candy cadet
you're good okay you gotta go buddy you
gotta go
swam
that's what i'm talking about let's
playtest that
oh right wasn't there like a super
wasn't the whole
oh god wasn't the whole crux of the
easter egg like about this
particular game
it wasn't
[Music]
wow
[Music]
i'm really trying guys i'm trying to go
as fast as i can
i don't remember like what the right
video was but
[Music]
yes i do
[Music]
oh magnet that's good
oh i'm gonna get stuck somewhere that i
don't want to be i know that for sure
but i know for a fact i'm gonna miss
some and it's gonna be impossible
oh god
i don't know where
oh no i've done the oh i've done the
exact thing i didn't want to do
which is like not know where i am
oh i goofed it
i goofed it
i goofed it hardcore i thought i saw
something here hello how are you okay
oh no i goofed it guys i goofed it
[Music]
it's loud
no way no way it's loud no way
no
the captain would never do that no way
i don't know where i'm going i'm
completely lost hello
[Music]
oh god i've screwed myself
i've boned
i goofed i've done this before with this
exact game somehow where i just oh there
you are
how did i miss that
but i didn't
go mugo
i was just 100 bucks wasn't really worth
it but whatever
whatever
i guess i'll buy the stage i don't have
enough for the animatronics but
maybe there'll be a cool discount next
time that'd be pretty cool
all right anyway
this place is looking good oh i could
put number one crate back on stage
hell yeah
now that is what i am talking about
what else could
[Music]
that's a crazy cool ball pit
look at all this gravity vortex holy
hell
look at you lefty
perfect
but
easy peasy you don't need to tell me
twice 15 bucks
unavailable
but i wanted
71 000 who's going to get that kind of
money me
soon
with my incredible animatronics store
or uh pizzeria whatever this is bam look
at him go
yeah
go lefty go
now this is a lineup
this is the lineup guys
this is a slice of something special
this is pretty good that's not bad
i got some play tokens left i guess i
could
do stuff
i know what i'll do
[Music]
my favorite thing about this game
[Music]
i just forget to love him
well i mean apparently i don't because
he's just
it's so
good
it's so well done it's so well done
anyway
all right
go back to fruity maze oh right that's
right i need to do the fruity maze again
ah sure let's do that
oh right oh weird oh
oh no i'm sad now
oh i went the wrong way oh god no
oh no
uh i forget exactly where i'm supposed
to go first
is it like the same layout
every time it might be
i might be hitting a dead end
i might be screwing myself oh i'm
screwed
i'm screwed
i've i've completely forgotten where all
the power ups are i've screwed myself
myself
anyway this is kind of sad
hi
let me go get the
magnet there that'll help
there we go
[Music]
why i went backwards i don't really know
but i did
something else
now
oh wow
i am choosing just the absolute worst
ways to go possibly
is this another way
go go now
collect all the dead puppies apparently
no no no time extend me spend my time
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no i'm trapped in a bad place i'm
trapped into bad place
i somehow screwed it even harder even
though i got all the bolts the bonuses
that i needed to i've screwed myself
okay time extension i think it's just
this top right area
[Music]
i didn't know you could go out of bounds
[Music]
this time not nearly as dumb
i might be just as dumb
i think somehow i'm being
no that's the dumb way
i want to get this
slug
first and then i can slip right through
here
to get the sweet power up that is
definitely up here there's it's 100 for
sure up there
don't go out of bounds because that's
bad i don't hit a dead end because
that's also
don't go out of bounds
[Music]
somehow
oh no
oh no where do i
how do i uh
oh no oh no
no i've done it again
oh no i goofed it
how do i keep goofing it
how how do i keep moving it
[Music]
how am i this terrible how how could i
pause oh here we go
[Music]
yes
i've done it
isn't there one more isn't there like an
even worse version
oh god
oh my goodness
[Music]
oh no no no
no power-ups oh boy
i would have to know this super well
i might be able to get this not that
it's gonna do me any good
well magically i used the travel through
walls power up to basically go the fact
that the news already set out for me
which is not exactly what i was hoping
for
i don't think that works either then how
do you do this if it's not
possible
uh
well
[Music]
that's interesting
i guess i'm done for the day
oh that's not good what did i just see
oh goodness gracious oh boy
oh boy that's not good
that's what
oh god
oh no
i saw that okay i need new equipment
please
oh boy oh boy
oh my god
oh my god
oh
god okay i forgot that this game can be
uh
oh my i'm doomed i'm doomed
okay i gotta do my things
i gotta do my things
i forgot that i needed to actually
buy upgrades for this [ __ ]
oh my god
i don't know i don't know
i rushes
oh i forgot that canceled it out
so oh boy
oh no
what was that
seem to be doing okay
this ain't too much of a problem
not a problem for two immortal gods like
us
am i right
i don't remember what i need to do when
they're actually there
do i just
almost done ordering things
okay
didn't i buy an upgraded printer
oh excuse me
what did i hear
oh my god
i don't like it i don't like it i don't
like it
i don't like it i don't like it at all
see if i can grab that guy up there
my work who knows
hey cut that [ __ ]
out is
is it a thing where oh my god i i need
to turn off the computer right that's a
thing
i need to turn off the computer
i think
oh my god
computer's noise okay that makes sense
doesn't make a lot of sense but it makes
sense
i'm done i'm done
i'm done
huh
okay
i got there i got there everybody i did
get there before you is an animatronic
found in the back alley we are unsure of
its origins
it is your job to complete the
maintenance checklist before claiming it
as salvage or if you choose to you can
throw it back into the alley where you
found it and forfeit payment please make
your choice now
oh i think we can salvage this bad boy
this thing looks good to me
you have chosen to proceed with the
maintenance yes i have remember use your
company as you taser to return the
animatronic to a neutral state if you
feel that it's becoming unstable or
aggressive
you can only use it three times before
it begins to damage the animatronic and
decrease its value
begin audio prompt in three
two one
the thing is i don't know what its
states of attack are
so i'm just gonna go based on how
threatened i feel by its aura document
results now usually
that's the smile an audio prompt that's
a smile that's not threatening
that's a delightful smile
is that a second nose
document results
nothing there oh you're just a delight
audio prompt in three look at you
one ain't you just the sweetest
smile trapped
look at you
what a bundle of sunshine you is
document results
nothing here
oh
[Music]
two
one
[Laughter]
document results
nothing there
same old charming look on his face
one
look at that look at that bundle of joy
you're still ain't so sweet
[Music]
document results ain't nothing to about
to do it
hey
i always come back
wait a minute where have i heard this
[Laughter]
i had a feeling you would get me
oh no
hey
but wait a minute
no
no wha
hey
no
parents union against unsafe atrocities
and mechanical abominations parents
[Music]
you can see where i got my acronyms from
young boy was hospitalized for 10 months
due to defended fast burning feminist
negligent preparation handling of food
stuff he contracted multiple parasites
from consumption of food and beverages
prepared
the parasites caused him suffer
explosive dysentery excluding painful
acute stomach cramps and terrible nausea
such horrible circumstances could have
been avoided if fast bear entertainment
inc simply followed approved standards
of care for the handling of foodstuffs
but for hasbro entertainment inc's cruel
indifference to human safety and health
he would not have suffered such
unnecessary harm and damage
uh well i'm gonna fight it this is
ludicrous we don't even serve food here
get out of here
yeah i can't help it if he was licking
the balls in the ball pit that's on him
that's not my fault
that's clearly not my fault
they're a child
a child's gonna do as a child do
all right
hold on a second
because there's something very important
that i have discovered
that i need to address
really soon in the meantime there's a
link down in the description that can
take you to in space with markiplier if
you want to give that a lovely watch
it's a bit of a
wormhole that you're going to find
yourself buried in but one second i'm
about to unleash upon you
one of the greatest things
i have
ever
seen in
my
many years
on this planet
now this might take some doing but let
me tell you when it is
so worth
what you are about to see you don't even
understand
the power with which i am about to imbue
upon you
and all that you know
you
and
everything
that you are and stand for
has been waiting for this one moment to
occur
but in the meantime you can check out
the uh link in the description below
so uh
just you wait
oh
it
is
everything you could have hoped for
everything and more i would say
everything and more
so hold on to your butts
it's about to get wild
well
hold on
hold on hold on hold on
hold hold
hold
but also there is a link to in space
with markiplier in the description below
if you if you've been noticing that i've
been
hyping up this show of mine it is now
officially out and you can watch it
feast your eyes
upon it
and you will see
it for all that it is
yes
interesting interesting interesting
interesting interesting
interesting hold on
i'm about to unlock the secrets of the
universe and it takes some doing it does
it do take some doing but i'm willing to
do it
damn you
hold on
hold on hold on
hold on
hold on
there we go
now i've got it
now i have it
i don't remember that
do i remember that
i don't remember this
i legitimately i've i
i don't remember that
but hold on
hold on
[Music]
are you ready
i settled that lawsuit and you know what
i did i countersued
that kid didn't know what the hell they
were doing and they were foolish to even
try to sue me
i won that case handedly
all of the college savings that that kid
was going to have is now in my pocket
thank you very much
all mine all 100 mine
i am incredible and i deserve this win
as i said to the child
and frankly i might sue them all over
again
because number one how dare they number
two how dare they and number three
how dare they
anyway did i get this i already bought
this okay but i need to upgrade this bam
all right now that is what i'm calling
a pizzeria
uh sponsorship absolutely
give me some of that gimme that all
right
yes balloon cart confetti floor
deluxe baltic disco light egg baby
neon party set gravity vortex
orville
the prize king
can't afford that
can't afford that can't afford that
but
i think we are well on our way
to really
really getting this
all right you gotta go get out of here
all right maybe you gotta go
number one crate all right let's get uh
you out of here what else do we have we
have
oh yeah oh the deluxe blue loon cart
let's see you are
behind my dresser whoa
now that's what i am talking about and
boom look at that thing
this doesn't quite balance out let me
put something else there the prize king
excellent now this is what i am
referring to
the gravity vortex
man look at that ball pit look at the
gravity vortex look at all this
delightful deliciousness
for something like that
balloon cart you know there's not even a
risk to these because they're so high
quality
there's not even a risk
you know else i'm gonna get i need
where is it
better speakers
deluxe speaker set that's what i am
talking about
there was nothing else
well yeah it's good enough for now
didn't i buy more animatronics
no i didn't yes i did i can buy more
animatronics
there we go
it ain't a five nights at freddy's
actually i guess we got a freddy no we
got ned that's not the same
and i ain't five nights at freddy's
without freddie
good i'm out of here
bam
now
we are
talking about this
gravity vortex what are you
oh my god
help me you okay
oh oh my god wait whoa oh control bad
okay christmas
oh my god
oh good lord
oh god i'm gonna get overwhelmed here oh
there i go
that's okay
i wonder if there's like a he's dead
oh look at me
all right let me go in the deluxe ball
pit
wow look at that what happens if you go
in the
oh
wow
[Music]
nailed it
[Music]
oh god no oh
no
all right
[Music]
oh god no
no
all right last try
okay
all right well
four thousand points
hey what about you prize king oh wow
[Music]
oh
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
okay there's got to be something in here
there's got to be something in here
there has to be something in here
[Music]
right there
there has to be something in here right
am i wrong am i wrong there's got to be
something in here
[Music]
there's gotta be something in here right
it's a gambling experience yeah you're
right about that yeah you're right about
that but i'm i'm
all right
there's nothing i don't believe you i
don't believe that there's nothing i
don't believe it
i'm gonna run out of coins
one token left but this is the one
everyone channel your energy into this
one
cool
well
that's okay
didn't need it anyway
didn't want it anyway i actually didn't
want any of that anyway
because we got a good piece of rear i
can't even get a balloon
that's okay
i guess i could
[Music]
nah
all right
oh i had another spot for a thing god
damn it
that's fine
oh egg baby oh i forgot about egg baby
okay it's fine i need to order
better things
all right so there's a lot of danger
here but it's okay
because i am not in danger
i am in the opposite of danger
why is this taking so long i thought i'd
fix it from the outside yeah i'll try
that
my problem was fixing it from the inside
i'm an idiot
don't wait but
the toilet oh the ad that's right
oh my god i forgot about how annoying
that was
one big happy family
oh that was a different intro oh
interesting
but anyway
i think that's probably a fitting end to
that
um
this has been delightful
honestly truly
it's quite delightful there's there's so
much to love about this one in
particular because
it's like got that kind of it scratches
an itch of customization that is really
nice um
but also
it is
just a super fun experience by itself
with all the easter eggs and all the
secrets and stuff like that
and it's just
i don't know it's just it's just pretty
pretty cool to see uh fyi i know that a
lot of people are asking about this uh i
unlisted the other live streams it's
literally because of the way that
youtube categorizes or organizes
uh live streams on the video page and i
know it doesn't matter that much but it
would have been it would have put those
streams above in space with markiplier
so
i unlisted them so that they wouldn't be
in the way of it literally that's how it
works because the actual video
for the first video of in space with
markiplier uh got unlisted
or uh it was uploaded before i did those
streams therefore it would have put it
behind those other videos
which would have made it harder to find
but don't worry i'm gonna put them in
the playlist for five nights at freddy's
along with this one this one is also
going to be unlisted but you can find it
in the five nights at freddy's playlist
now also
i did want to say thank you guys
seriously sincerely from the bottom of
my heart
thank you
for
watching space
it
is truly and 100 a labor of love that
has involved the work of
well over a hundred people
put their time and effort into making
that
show a reality and the fact that you
guys have chewed it up loved it adored
it
made art of it already and it hasn't
even been out a week yet
thank you
sincerely truly thank you for enjoying
it
there is a part two
part two is coming i actually just flew
back
from
uh austin
after the last
sound session
for part two and i know there's a
spoiler if you haven't seen it yet go
watch it it doesn't spoil anything of
the experience but it's kind of a
spoiler that there is part two if you go
look at the link in the description
below and you go to that video it'll say
in space with markiplier part one that's
because there is a part two coming
and
part two
i think you're gonna love
part two
even more than you love part one
and i know there's a lot of you that
really really love it and really enjoyed
it
i cannot wait for you to see
part two
i do have a lot of work left to do
uh to get it ready there there's still
tons of stuff that needs to be done
before it gets up there
but just truly
thank you
and if i could ask a favor
it's my 10-year anniversary after all
therefore it's technically my or it was
my 10-year anniversary but it is still
the 10-year anniversary week
please help me spread the word about the
show
if you loved it if you really truly
loved it
share with a friend
tell a family member about it get anyone
to watch it
i love seeing people enjoy the show and
so much work beyond just my own has gone
into the show i would love to see the
community get together and find out
creative ways to spread the word about
this show because i am immensely proud
of it but i'm also immensely proud of
the work that my friends that my
co-workers that my collaborators that
everyone on the team behind the scenes
of making the show has put into it and
their hard work deserves to be
recognized i legitimately think that
when this is all said and done
it it will be something that's
important
i think that like not i i don't think
that about a lot of the stuff that i do
certainly pokemon smasher pass is not an
important video
but this one to me
like the fact that i was able to have
this be my 10-year anniversary video
in space with markiplier
that's so special to know that i came
like 10 years
of wanting to do stuff like this to
getting to this point where i
can do stuff like this it's not even
that i want to or i'm dreaming of it i
literally can
do stuff like this i've learned so much
just in the past
year of
making this about making bigger projects
and
yeah i'm just proud of it you know
i'm just
i'm really proud of it
so
if you haven't seen it yet definitely go
check it out please go check it out link
is in the description you will not
regret it it is a fun time ask anyone
that's seen it
and then
it's going to be a little bit of a wait
but
may 2nd
part 2
and a few extra surprises
on the way to part two
that's gonna be good
i told you it was big i told you i told
you i told you
and i think you're gonna look forward to
some of the surprises in part two
but please do
help spread the word about it
i need your help
i desperately do uh i mean it's not like
a
it's not like it's not getting a great
response but just like
i can't do it without you
and now is the time that we can all
help show
the world what
he can do with just an idea
and 10 years of time
i'm really proud
i really am
so thank you
check it out link in the description
it's right down there or on my channel
in space with markiplier
and it won't be much longer until you
see some really cool stuff coming your
way
so thank you
and as always
i will see you through the link in the
description below because it's right
down there
why are you still here
all right if you got ideas for helping
spread around let me know all right
and uh also the discord there's a
discord
i have a discord i don't know if you
knew that i haven't advertised it much
at all i should open that up again
mods i should open that up again maybe
we should get a link get people in
discord
that might be fun
we could all brainstorm together
yeah
yeah let's open the floodgates
let's open the i should open the
screaming room on the discord
that's a great idea
that's the best idea
i should open up the screaming room
hang on guys
hang on
i got this i got this my mods are so on
board with this they are so into this
idea hold on
there's one more thing
yeah
yeah
that'll that'll break it whatever it's
it's not going to break it it'll be fine
it'll be fine it'll be fine
i'll just crank
i'll just crank down
the bit rate it'll be
lowest bit rate possible
it'll be totally fine
maybe i'll maybe i'll keep
i'll keep
i'll keep it at 99 people that won't
break it right that won't break it
right
something like that anyway i'm gonna
create an invite to the discord if you
guys haven't been there oh wait no the
mods have a discord there's there's an
invite right there the mods are posting
it i've opened up the screen well i
haven't opened up yet but i'm going to
open up the screaming room
and
advanced permissions okay everyone can
no one video no activity
yes use
voice activity no priority speakers
no muting members
no
deafening other members no
other members
well i shouldn't set that to no i don't
know how to use discord properly this is
why i'm going to break things
probably
if i want the mods to be able to do that
i should just set that generally
this is
fine it's open for business
the
i think it's open for business
oh yeah it's open
all right so if you want to get in the
discord uh the link is being posted in
the chat right now
uh you will start out in i don't know if
any of the bots are set up i don't know
if anything is set up for new
uh users right now um
it's already breaking well you know
oh right i didn't prune members i should
prune members this is hold on guys this
is going to take a little more doing
than i thought this is this is what we
call live maintenance let me put on some
music for you guys
all right this is the music that will
hear as the entire server breaks down
uh prune
we never got the permissions to change
things can't control this
ah
well it's the screaming room what's to
control
it's fine it's fine everything's fine
there's a link to this discord
in the chat right now
and through this we will use our
collective brain power
to help
blast out the word
of in space with markiplier to the
entire world
right i'm ready for genius ideas i will
create a bounty for those that obtain
the most views for this
i will create a reward system of some
sort
non-legally binding disclaimer
um
how do i
[Music]
do anything
in space mark uh available now for free
uh
oh yeah no way hang on hang on
right
okay
okay
uh
okay
right
okay
hmm
uh
hold on
i'm literally uh
i might be breaking everything
oh oops i was changing the rumpus room
that's not right
well it helps if i'm actually changing
the right room let me add
right okay i need to add
membership
okay
now the mods can do stuff maybe
people's laptops are overheating because
of the discord stripper
how can it be breaking it can't possibly
be breaking there's no way it's breaking
there's no breaking this
there's no breaking this
there's no breaking it it's unbreakable
it's
time tested
it's battle hardened it's hardest battle
okay that's everyone view channel
you can view it
can you connect to it
i'm gonna change that
what does that do
right
your mac is gonna explode why is
everyone's computer separating
i've figured out how to destroy
everyone's stuff that's great that's
great i love that i love that for us
okay there we go did i do something did
i do something i think i set something
right i think i said something or is
that a sarcastic thanking me for what
i've been doing
i think
there's a guy just screaming at the top
of his lungs it is called the screaming
room so i'm pretty sure that's for the
purpose
i uh
genuine and sarcastic
you have no new permissions well about
that i don't really know how permissions
work
in this
so
but i think you can move deaf and mute
and priority speaker things you should
be able to
i i've destroyed you
what if i
can i make it so that no one can deafen
themselves in the screaming room if
you're in the screaming room you must be
subjected to the screaming
no i don't think i can change that
someone probably could be
hmm
anyway how many people did i have in
this server
should i prune
should i prove should i prune
mods should i prune
should i prune
okay you you you've got things
okay so mods can now mod that
right
all right i know i'm shutting down the
screamer
screaming room's a terrible idea
screaming room is literally the worst
idea i've ever had
i'm gonna
make it
i'm you can
view it but you can't connect to it or
speak speaking it
screaming room's closed
get out
and hold on hold hold hold
hold hold
private channel there we go
now i've got it
no not private i want people to see what
happened
did that work is it
yeah the mods you mods you can scream in
there
oh right i could do that i can make it
so everyone can connect to it but no one
can speak
ah that is what i did
i'm a genius
there you go
now mods can scream
anyway
oh aka the rumpus room yeah that is what
that room is for
i forgot
god the screaming room's such a terrible
idea
why did i ever want that
i want to open it back up again
i really want to open it back up again
all right anyway so uh
let me make it so that nobody can
connect to it because it there's already
a room that's
for that get out of here get out of here
everybody get out
get out get out
get out of here
get out they'll filter out eventually
uh it should be so that no one can join
again i don't know
shouldn't it be
shouldn't
maybe
i don't know how discord works but i do
know how space works as you can see in
in space with markiplier my latest show
it's the weekend why not binge it a
little bit you'll enjoy it guaranteed
available for free on my channel right
now link is in the description below why
not share with a friend why not tell a
co-worker about it why not tell your
worst enemy about it so that they get
lost in the madness of the wormhole for
all time
it'll be the best way to rid them
okay
i think i got it
i think i did
okay anyway uh
have fun on the discord i'm gonna go now
take care of yourselves take care of
each other and
help me out with your brilliant ideas
from how to uh
promote the ever loving
[ __ ] out of space all right i'm gonna go
bye love you